I'm Gabriel isando I'm al Jazeera's
Brazil correspondent certain things here
have been made better because of some of
the projects for the World Cup I think
they'll Brazil's a very big country it's
hard to just generally say that there's
been massive improvements think
certainly there's been some reporting
that has probably been grossly
exaggerated in another sense there has
been some really strong reporting some
of them are very much legitimate the
city of Rio they've been in a tough spot
because when they started this about
seven years ago there were favelas that
were completely dominated by armed drug
traffickers and these were just a few
blocks away from tourist hotels the city
and the government has regained presence
in some of these favelas that they did
not have presence in before there's
still a lot of social projects that need
to be brought into those communities to
really advance beyond simply taking the
drug traffickers out
I think Brazilians if they are able to
separate football with social problems
that they're on the streets protesting
about they have issues that they want
addressed whether it be health care
education in the economy and I don't
think that the World Cup necessarily is
going to mean when World Cups over there
just going to give up on all those sites
or polls indicate now that the
incumbents Dilma Rousseff has a pretty
comfortable lead however are the people
that do say here in Brazil that if
Brazil wins the world cup and it goes
off the successfully Dilma Rousseff will
no doubt be reelected I don't know if
that's really the case and I think
Brazilians are pretty savvy I think
they're going to look at the world cup
whether it be success a failure or
somewhere in between and then they're
going to make their decisions on broader
issues about who they want to vote for